axel courson bonjour bonjour merci nous
accueillir dans votre brasserie on est à
guyancourt et vous venez de vous
installer
j'aimerais pas wen a très longtemps oui
non pas trop fabriqué brasser de la
bière
voilà donc on va faire connaissance avec
vous déjà vous êtes très jeune vous avez
28 ans c'est ça j'ai 28 ans nom du maroc
je m'appelle axel je viens de 50 ans
donc j'ai grandi à
montigny-le-bretonneux juste à côté et
j'avais à coeur
une passion pour la bière oui j'avais à
coeur de 17 patients doit transformer en
projets et après en métier et du coup
m'est venue l'idée d'ouvrir une fabrique
de bière à saint quentin en yvelines qui
est le territoire dans lequel j'ai
grandi
voilà mais alors avant sa série une vie
parce que ça fait combien de temps vous
êtes à steenvoorde moi ça fait un peu
moins d'un an que je m'installe un peu
moins d'allant que la bière existe et
que vous que la commercialiser c'est ça
on élections
alors avant physique quoi avant je
faisais de l'audit financier
je travaille dans la finance donc je
travaillais à paris à neuilly sur seine
est un petit peu partout aussi en france
rien à voir je porter le costume cravate
je prenais le train tous les matins pour
aller bosser
j'ai fait ça pendant un peu plus de
trois ans depuis trois ans mais malgré
tout ma passion m'a rattrapé et un cette
passion de la bière alliende ou voilà
alors elle vient pas déjà quand j'étais
jeune j'adorais en boire sa session j'en
ai plus beaucoup et va tout va bien tout
va bien je fais du sport
et oui je me suis intéressé à ça la
fabrication de la bière en fait j'ai vu
assez rapidement sur internet qu'on
pouvait se procurer des kits pour la
fabriquer à la maison donc j'ai fait pas
mal de brassens chez moi si vous voilà
des petites et est ce que je faisais
donc je faisais ça dans ma cuisine avec
une grosse marmite une passoire
si tu faisais faire monter dans des
seaux que je mettais dans la salle de
bains cacher et voilà j'ai fait pas mal
de bras 5e j'ai fait goûter indien grâce
à ça veut dire quoi
un brassens et faire une faire une
recette de pertes
c'était entre quelle que soit la
quantité
moi je brasse et entre 15 et 20 litres à
chaque fois et
maintenant je passe un petit peu plus et
voilà et je la faisais goûter à mes amis
à la famille et c'était voilà c'est très
artisanal président l'accusé et je
m'amusais tellement de travail de
gouttes d'eau critères financiers
éthiques a refusé ok et alors on vous a
félicité et c'est bon ça m'a beaucoup
encouragé au mois de juin quand on fait
de la bière déjà connaître quelqu'un qui
fait de la bière c'est vraiment très
c'est très rare et du coup j'ai fait
goûter des bières qui était forcément
différente de ce que les gens trouver
dans le commerce ou dans les bars et du
coup on m'a beaucoup encouragé parce que
les boues étaient différents et ayew
était plutôt sympa et donc vous achetiez
des kits vous arriviez à donner votre
pâte et avoir votre bière avec une
recette personnelle
on sortait la différence c'est ça voilà
c'est ça qui est intéressant c'est ça
qui était intéressant après j'ai
perfectionné la les recettes ans je me
suis acheté des livres ou explique en
détail comment bras ces différentes
étapes et j'ai trouvé des fournisseurs
de malte où j'ai pu choisir les malt
d'orge que j'utilise est important c'est
très important dans la bière tout ce qui
est sélection des ingrédients que ce
soit les malte où les houblons donc moi
j'ai pu j'ai pu les choisir et c'est en
fonction de vos goûts et du résultat que
vous souhaitiez obtenir exactement
c'était très expérimentale au début ça
je vous le cache pas chaque fois que je
vois c'est au début c'était un petit peu
la surprise sur le résultat mais le losc
a été assez bon et très encourageant
pour la suite d'accords dont vous avez
travaillé avec une optique d'obtenir une
recette qui vous conviennent
parfaitement
et après ce jour là où es tu dis quoi
moi je me suis dit mais bon voilà quoi
je peux quitter mon ancien mon ancienne
vie
étudiez vraiment ce projet de monter une
brasserie parce qu'en plus d'avoir une
bonne bière après c'est vraiment écrit
une entreprise à plein temps là dedans
dans la partie création d'entreprise
trouver des financements trouver un
local trouver du matériel brassage et
étudier les débouchés le marché je me
suis mis là dans cette phase là ça a
duré un peu plus de six mois
on est inquiet j'ai vraiment j'ai monté
un gros dossier je suis allé voir
beaucoup de gens pour défendre ce projet
ça a été compliqué ça a été pas toujours
simple mais j'ai été accompagné par la
chambre des métiers qui j'ai eu après
des aides et un suivi par la maison de
l'entreprise de 50 ans donc ça m'a
beaucoup aidé
sur sur cette phase-là d'études et de
lancement vous avez trouvé cet endroit
en tournée avec lui en cours dans une
zone industrielle dont wells et la zone
d'activités du moulin à vent 6 rue jean
moulin et dans ce local que j'ai prise
donc en décembre 2013 pour lequel j'ai
eu un vrai coup de coeur parce que la
disposition fait que dès qu'on rentre on
voit l'appareil de production et du coup
quand moi je reçois le public
c'est que je voulais mettre en avant la
partie locale partie à la fabrication
artisanale soit retissé locale tu le
public puisse voir qui est le brasseur
et ouais c'est pas bien et pour pouvoir
après discuter échanger sur la barre ok
donc maintenant c'est parti la
fabrication vous fait combien de goûter
par par semaine en leur genre à peu près
1200 bouteilles par semaine pour le
moment j'ai une capacité de production
qui est supérieur mais je suis en train
de développer toute la partie
commerciale donc si je pouvais lui
rappelle je fais tout moi-même je suis
producteur le commercial le commerçant
le gestionnaire le communiqué j'essaie
de se caler tout ça au mas semaines et
donc le produit
je produis et je vends donc une bière
blonde qui s'appelle la cin q la blonde
et l'ambré la cin q en bray voilà donc
oui non c'est bien ça vient d'où ce nom
alors ce nom il vient autres les fêtes
conçoit alors à saint-quentin alors on
va chercher un nom qui rappelait qui
rappelait la zone de saint quentin
moi qui ai grandi remontée du bon dieu
quand j'étais j'étais ado avec mes
copains quand on a étrenné au quartier
du centre commercial de
à côté de la gare des 51 dizaines de
quartiers on l'appelait son cul et du
coup le nom de là il est et puis moi ça
moi ça me rappelle cette époque là et
puis c'est un rappel aux saint
quentinois le cin q c'est là la zone de
50 voilà c'est ça très bien
donc vous vous faites deux bières
différentes une blonde une ambrée ce
soir pour l'instant en petites
bouteilles de 33 cl une fois voilà alors
vous allez m'expliquer
concrètement comment on fait la bière
finalement vous c'est de là bien après
ce que j'ai l'impression qu'on peut en
faire partout oui puisqu'on ici voilà
donc vous faites venir vos matières
premières mais le match à son bios c'est
ça voilà déjà et donc qu'est ce qu'il ya
comme matière alors on a déjà de l'eau
beaucoup de zéros moi je prends l'eau du
réseau de bus en cours que je fais
préalablement chauffé un peu plus 80
degrés pour évaporer tout ce qu'ils
avaient les clubs pour l'assainir oui la
terrifiait pour la purifier et ensuite
du malt d'orge
donc c'est du grain d'orge qui et malté
de malfaçons voilà ce qu'on peut voir là
du malt d'orge leblond donc c'est du
grain qui ait germé pendant quelques
jours et ensuite il est cuit plus ou
moins fort par le malt heures le maire
john picard ça vous l'avez sélectionnés
en fonction de votre goût sachant ce que
ça allait donner après exactement ce que
je voulais faire
alors ce mal tout bon là on va
l'utiliser un petit peu dans toutes les
bières mais en grande quantité c'est la
base de tout est bien mais on va
l'utiliser en très grande quantité dans
les médias redon ensuite on peut
utiliser des malts qui sont un petit peu
plus coloré donc j'ai des échantillons
dans les po donc celui-là il a un tout
petit peu plus coloré
il a été cuit il a été un petit peu
torréfié comme le café le griller ce
sont deux là il ya des notes un peu de
chocolat un peu calmé
vous sert à faire la bière la bière
anglaise alors faire de ça sert à faire
de la bonne voie pour le moment je fais
pas encore des bières brunes mais quand
je lui en suis là je l'utiliserai ça
sera pour les recettes de bière brune et
pourquoi vous n'avez pas fait de la
bière blonde et la bière brune tout de
suite alors et pour le public les gens
sont plus habitués à blaringhem chinois
je pense voir beaucoup moins de bière
brune que puisque deux garnements
après ces continents et qui meublent les
franciliens après je voulais faire une
bière un petit peu spécial donc je
partis sur une bière ambrée mai
voilà les prochaines je pense que je
vais faire une une nouvelle recette je
pense pas que ça sera la brute de
l'année prochaine ce sera sûrement une
bière blanche au quai de rivière blanche
est ce que ce sont les mêmes leur s 14
et on n'a pas fini qu'on n'a pas fait du
bien ça et après je vois ces petites
croquettes pour alors ça c'est du
houblon donc le houblon c'est
le houblon donc c'est une plante
grimpante qui pousse moi je me fournis
en alsace donc on récolte des olives au
bureau bio bio est encore une fois
monsieur fonctionnant tout bio et bio
c'est du houblon donc le houblon ça on
récolte sur la plante on récolte des
cônes déconne qu'ils sont
qui sont utilisés moi moi je les ai sous
forme de pellets donc ils sont hachés
frais forme de pellets ça s'appelle des
places du titre voilà c'est peut-être
enquête on appelle ça déplaît ils sont
arrachés frais une fois récoltées sur
l'art mais ensuite il est là cette
poudre et compactés sous forme de
pellets donc voilà pour les ingrédients
donc on a de l'eau du malt d'orge et
2010 au nom que vous avez sélectionné
votre goût et de votre aile de la
recette q la recette que je veux mettre
au point donc comment après on fait la
bière
donc ce que je fais je prendre l'eau
chaude je vais mélangé à de l'eau chaude
du malt d'orge que j'ai préalablement
concassés en une fine très agacé du malt
blonde que joe baca semaine avec un même
bien voilà j'ai un moulin à grains qui
me concas ça je brasse donc je mélange
l'eau chaude et le gras dans cette phase
de brassage qui va se passer c'est que
l'amidon du grain va se désagréger en
sucre et les sucres ils vont passer dans
l'eau donc après on va filtrer pour
récupérer ce jus sucré qu'on va appeler
du mou et le mou je vais le mettre à
bouillir dans m'accuse de cuisson une
fois qu'il va se mettre à bouillir je
vais mettre mes houblon dedans qui lui
va à infuser il va amener de l'amertume
de la bien et s'il va amener les parfums
de la bière donc on va le faire infuser
un petit peu comme quand vous faites
votre thé le matin et alors quand on pas
de bien de près tant de bien de noël etc
ça veut dire quoi parce que à vous
écouter on allait me sens qu'il ya pas
de saison y'a pas de vendanges comme
pour le raid 1 on en a toute l'année du
houblon et de l'ange avec de l'orge
ça veut dire quoi c'est bien alors si on
veut bien que ce soit un petit peu plus
typé la bière de printemps est souvent
un petit peu plus légère en alcool et
est-ce que l'or j'étoufferai en fait
c'est le moment de l'année où on va la
brasser et c'est aussi c'est aussi mais
le monde a changé elle est parfaitement
on peut on peut brasser une bière de
printemps un petit peu plus tard dans
l'année la bière c'est une question de
goût mais c'est une question de moment
voilà on va faire des bières plus ou
moins fortes plus ou moins rondes plus
ou moins épicé en fonction des saisons
donc on peut se dire qu'en hiver ou à
noël son existence de faire exactement
prochain et cette guerre aura plus de
corps un peu plus cher sera donc un peu
bien charpenté en effet un petit peu
plus épicée on va je vais jeter dedans
des épices qui rappelle un petit peu les
vins chauds de noël ou le parent le pays
je vais peut-être mais je vais
l'alcoolisme un petit peu plus pour
réchauffer réchauffer les coeurs connan
l'hiver ouais la bière de printemps à la
marcel va être plus légère plus plus sur
des notes tout ce végétal pour voilà
voilà désaltérer puis rappelé ce dernier
il ya plein de choses à dire en juin
dernier point la bière et la nourriture
commence à les accords mets et bières
existe alors il ya deux ans la trame sur
croûte que tu rajoutes labeur moquer un
peu après vous avez essayé des recettes
avec votre bière moi j'ai essayé des
recettes des accords entre la bière
blonde marche bien avec le tout ce qui
est volaille ou des fromages assez léger
ce qu'ils peuvent pour moi je le landais
le goût d'un u boat la bière ambrée
marche comme elle est un petit peu plus
de corps un petit peu plus de goût
marche bien avec les viandes rouges où
certains poissons
certains poissons aussi vous allez tirer
quoi je vais essayer avec du saumon et
et quelques poissons des rivières si ça
marchait pas mal et ensuite la bière
brune moi je trouve qu'elle fonctionne
très bien avec tout ce qui est des
serres chocolatées ou à la cerise
touskiflot la bière rien voilà on peut
la barque à écouter un gros merci bien
sûr mais un bravo pour votre entreprise
votre initiative et puis votre genre
quoi
hier un peu partout dans le monde
personne n'a trouvé oui entre entre
versailles rambouillet et aussi bas
beaucoup sur saint quentin en yvelines
sur toute la zone
s'il est de plus en plus voilà je
démarche je suis plus en plus sollicité
parce que c'est un produit qui plaît et
mes côtés ben je savais qu'ici à bientôt
à bientôt
merci